from washington d.c to chicago to los
angeles and here at home reproductive
rights groups are holding the bans off
our bodies day of action here in the
valley a rally was held at sunset park
madison kimbrough joins us live there
with more medicine
this turnout today has been huge it
started at five and i want you to take a
look behind me as about 200 people are
here donating t-shirts holding up signs
all coming together for one message
that's being pro-choice this rally is
the second to be hosted by planned
parenthood votes nevada along with
several other community members the
first was held earlier in the month in
front of the federal courthouse downtown
several community members and officials
including our own governor sisilak is
here and shared some words women and men
are calling on federal lawmakers and the
biden heritage administration to act
with urgency to protect a woman's right
to choose an abortion now here's what
one local father of two girls had to say
about showing up today
enough to be able to have for and take
care of for
not everyone has that luxury or
or you know or wants that and that's
that's what choice is all about and
that's
that's why i'm here
right now abortion is still legal up to
24 weeks across the country here in
nevada it's protected by the state's
constitution but for 26 other states
come this summer it could be banned this
rally concluded about 30 minutes ago but
as you can see there is still a large
presence here so there is really no
telling how long people will beg